hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about g-actin and f-actin in
microfilaments and what the distinctions
or the differences
between g-actin and f-actin are
so first let's just quickly revisit the
idea of microfilaments microfilaments
are part of the eukaryotic cytoskeleton
now remember that the cytoskeleton
includes things like microfilaments uh
microtubules intermediate filaments and
i do have another video comparing and
contrasting those different elements of
the cytoskeleton so check that out if
you're interested
going back specifically though to the
microfilaments these are also known as
actin
filaments because they are composed
of a monomer
called
g-actin now the g here stands for
globular
okay so this is talking about like a
single globular
protein g actin
now the gf and monomers assemble into a
polymer the polymer made up of those g
actin monomers is known as f actin
where the f stands for
filament
so filament or filamentous so here we
can see this soluble g-actin and here
the insoluble f-actin filament
now the f-actin is composed of two
twisted chains
of g-actin that's been assembled into
the f-actin filament
now this polymerization
of d-actin into f-actin requires that
g-actin first
bind atp
now i want to just make a note here that
if you're interested in polymerization
how monomers are linked together to form
polymers you can check out a video that
i have on dehydration synthesis
reactions and hydrolysis reactions which
is kind of how depolymerization
works so you can check out that video if
you're interested
now specifically the polymerization of
g-actin into f-actin
it involves three different phases and
we're going to talk about those three
phases right up here
so the first one is called nucleation
this is when the atp has has bound so
what we can see here and added these
little green
circles onto the soluble g actin to show
that they are bound to atp
once that has happened
a
stable complex called a nucleus
so a stable complex of g actin just like
a few g actin
um see i pictured it here with three
forms something called a nucleus and the
second step is elongation and that's
where you have
growth
at either end of the nucleus so
basically growing by adding g-actin
monomers on
this thing is going to grow
and assume this filament form now the
third
the third phase is called the steady
state phase or sometimes the stationary
phase
and this is where you can have some
g-actin exchange at the ends like maybe
some g actin pops off but then it's
replaced with another one but there's no
net
growth
when it's in that that steady state
phase
now i've been pointing at this process
throughout the video
and you can see here i've got the atp
binding the nucleation the formation of
that nucleus right there i'll go ahead
and label
that
and then the elongation into that
insoluble f-actin filament
i do want to make sure you realize that
this process is more complex than what
is shown here there's multiple
regulatory proteins involved
that i have not depicted here i also
want to make sure you realize that
there is such a thing as actin
remodeling you know the cell is using
these microfilaments for a variety of
functions if you want more details on
that remember to check out my video on
the cytoskeleton
so you can have the microfilament you
could the cell might need to break it
down on one end or that's the d
polymerization
or might need to grow it on the other
end that would be more polymerization
and so i want you to see here i've got
these small little green dots remember
that's indicating atp
there's going to be atp present wherever
there's polymerization happening meaning
growth of that microfilament
and then where the atp has been pulled
off or
actually where that phosphate group has
been pulled off into instead of an atp
there's an adp there's more information
on on that if you check out my
dehydration synthesis video but where
there's only a dp
left that's where you're going to have
depolymerization or like breakdown down
that now i've been um doing something
new with my videos and that is taking a
picture of the final board so if you
want a pdf it's free a free pdf of this
board with all of the answers filled in
check out the tiny url in the
description below and thank you for
watching biology professor and i will
see you guys next time for more free
study videos thanks for watching